welcome back to this friday edition of
pft live we had so much fun yesterday
with our draft of the teams
over which we'd want full madden
franchise mode control
that we decided to flip it around the
teams that we want no part of
in madden franchise mode those are the
selections they may make appearances on
the flip side today
uh but i i just
it it was so strange because i never
quite know are we talking about the real
world
are we talking about the game and and
today we're going to try to make it real
world and only real world
madden style all right miles you've got
a question
for me and it will determine the first
pick what do you got i
i do have the trivia question all right
so happy 79th birthday
to vikings hall of famer paul krauss who
was the team mike
that drafted him washington
boom yes wow
come on producers made it too easy for
you
yeah no it's i i remember
because when i was a kid that's not how
it worked you only played for the team
the drafted you that's how the nfl was
rarely if ever i mean yeah they had
trades
but there was no free agency you were i
remember there was a point where the
cowboys and the steelers
had entirely homegrown players no one
else from any other team at any time
played for them other than the teams
that they drafted and signed as
undrafted free agents so
i remember that was significant when i
heard oh wait a minute he played for
washington but
paul krauss did and uh and drew pearson
pushed off i thought
i thought it was going that way but you
know paul krauss was a little bit late
getting over to help out nate wright on
that play as well
uh so that's part of that debacle from
december 28 1975 but i digress
pick number one for me without question
the houston texans
i want nothing to do with the franchise
mode control of that team because you're
stepping into
trading away assets i'm trading away my
best quarterback and and this is where
it slips into madden mode
you want to have a great quarterback
especially a mobile quarterback to be
successful running an offense in madden
except
when you're a high-end guy who i saw the
contest last year where the guy used a
punter
and just ran the ball with i want a
quarterback so
i know my quarterback's not happy the
team has been gutted
uh the only good news about it madden
style is you wouldn't have the
equivalent of a jack easter bee to deal
with but in the real world you would
i would want nothing to do with it
although i know the first move i would
make if i was in full control of the
texans for one year
the guy on the screen to the left would
no longer be employed by the texans that
would be move number one
maybe maybe i do want maybe i'm the
wrong day maybe that should be my first
pick yesterday
yeah well then you could get you know
four first round picks for two
if i'm the general manager of miami uh
so i think my first pick here would
probably be the falcons because
you have in aging matt ryan you have an
aging julio jones you don't have much
cap room you've got the fourth overall
pick which you could use to draft on a
qb you could maybe not you could maybe
sure up your offensive line maybe get
something on defense i don't necessarily
know what you want to do but
there's a lot of work that you have to
do in order to get the falcons to be in
a place where they could possibly be
super bowl contenders again
and right now i think that's a process
that's going to take years
and it's not necessarily something
that's going to be done this particular
year so
for my first pick i don't know that i
would want to be the falcons although at
least
if you are the falcons in madden like i
was talking about yesterday they have
some
decent uniforms especially their
throwbacks i don't necessarily know
about that gradient thing that they're
doing with that one uniform but other
than that
you know the falcons have some nice
uniforms they play in a cool stadium
yeah i would take out especially their
throwbacks and just say they have some
decent uniforms if we only let them wear
their throwbacks the new uniforms
not good in my opinion for the atlanta
falcons cap situation
horrendous for the falcons this year
that is that is another reason
to not want to have full control of that
franchise in 2021. next one for me the
detroit lions
i'm not big into the whole kneecap
biting thing that's one of the reasons
why i would shy away from it but the
cupboard is bare and jared goff is the
quarterback what do you do
around jared goff i think this is a team
that is deliberately taking a step back
i think they're going to be very bad
this year and i know as i'm saying it
there's a chance this clip is going to
get played in january
when they make the playoffs but i think
of all the teams right now in the nfl if
i had to pick one
most likely to do anything significant
this year it's a detroit lions
yeah i i think the lions are a good pick
and they were on my list too
um but i would have to go with the
saints for my next pick in part because
look you're not gonna have drew brees
anymore i mean that just
we talk about the coming days it seems
like you know drew brees's retirement
announcement has been coming from the
coming days for the last
however many weeks so from that
perspective you may have jameis winston
at qb you may want to mutate some hill
at qb
i don't know but they're in another
situation where their their their cap
situation
really really is not good so gotta get
rid of a lot of players you're gonna
have to figure out how you can
still be a contending team with not
without your hall of fame quarterback i
just don't know that i
want any part of that in trying to make
them
a super bowl contender in the nfc south
again
i mean they still have some very good
players under contract but you're right
they're gonna have to make some tough
decisions to clear up some cap space
to get the team in position where it can
even function and
sean payton one of the best coaches of
the past generation if not ever
gonna have a hard time getting the most
out of whatever he has left after they
throw these guys overboard so i agree
with you that's one that i would not
want
i i don't want the bears right now i i
who's my quarterback gonna be i don't
know it feels like there's no clear
option out there that makes me feel like
i can placate the media or the fans
everyone's under pressure to perform
this year i mean
that's the problem with getting that
vote of confidence one more year
not that they said one more year but
that's the message it comes through
hey you get to keep doing your job but
you have even more stress and pressure
because you know that if you have a bad
season in 2021
it's going to be over and whoever they
get to be the quarterback is going to
walk through the door with that kind of
burden on his shoulders so
not a lot of great options uh maybe you
could try to pull together some sort of
a trade for deshawn watson
i don't know that watson even wants to
go there i don't know why
he would frankly at this stage of his
career
um and how hard would it be to justify
giving up
a bunch of draft capital to go get
deshaun watson when you could have had
him
four years ago that's the first mental
hurdle the bears have to get past we
could have had him
how can we give up all this stuff to go
get the guy that we could have had
so i for those reasons and plenty of
others the bears are not a team i'd want
to have full control over this offseason
oh no i wouldn't want full control over
the bears either but i i'm going to stay
in the midwest though for my next pick
maybe the cincinnati
bengals and i think they're in a tough
spot
in part because of just the devastating
nature of joe burrow's injury you know
you don't necessarily know how well he's
going to come back
from that knee and he's been saying all
the right things you know he says
he's been making progress when he talks
to the cincinnati media i think
they're in late january so he's walking
and he's doing all these things but
you're still in a situation now where
zach taylor may or may not
get through the entire next season
before getting fired we don't
necessarily know that
there's just not necessarily been much
progress made
along either side of the ball for the
cincinnati bengals
so in that instance i just don't know
that that's a team that you really want
full control over because
how in the world are you going to make
it through this season and you know
you've got teams in your division
that whatever pittsburgh does they're at
least still going to be a middling team
right you've got cleveland that's still
ascending the ravens still have lamar
jackson they're still going to be good
you're not in a great division for even
just in terms of trying to compete
that's a tough spot there i wouldn't
want any part of cincinnati
yeah the joe borough injury was so
devastating and
who knows if he's going to be ready week
one and it just feels like
even as that team stumbles into a great
quarterback
are they going to be able to put the
rest of the pieces around him
hopefully for bro they will it's it's
going to be a wait and see thing and i
agree with you i would not want the
reigns there i'm going to take one of
the teams that you had yesterday i'm
going to take the jets
i just feel like the jets even with the
second overall pick and even with robert
saul
as the head coach i feel like they have
so far to go to get to where they need
to be
because of the mike mccagnan approach
trying to build the team from the
outside
in now you've got joe douglas who's
trying to build from the inside
out i feel like they still need multiple
more pieces before they get to the point
where you
feel like you can even remotely contend
i would love going out and signing every
free agent receiver that i could find
every fast guy every guy with a 96 speed
rating just sign him up
but you know quarterback situation is a
problem skill positions are a problem
and that's what makes your team go in
madden here's where i slip into madden
mode who cares about your offensive line
it's not like you need to have a bunch
of road graders it's about having
receivers who can get open
running backs who can pop through and
quarterbacks that can buy time until
somebody's open
and it feels like the jets have none of
those things right now miles
yeah no i would agree with you on that
for sure i just i don't know where you
can go with the jets and it's going to
take
multiple years uh okay but i wanted like
if i were
just playing pure madden mode i would
probably say that the buccaneers
would be my last pick because i i mean
you already basically have everything so
what do you know there's nothing to do
but i would say
it would be the eagles because right now
you just got rid of carson wentz
you know you have jalen hurts but there
are just so many questions
on both sides of the ball how are you
really going to be able to get better
i don't know that that's a team that you
really want to have full control over
right now because
even though they're in the lowly nfc
east it's going to be hard for them to
be able to compete i think
next year especially with the first year
head coach and i'm telling you
winning that super bowl has turned that
fan base into like a
rabid crazed dog that wants another
super bowl and they are even more
impatient than they were
before they won the first one and they
need to be
patient this year as this team takes a
step back
and tries to figure out where it's going
from here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports